maintenant qu'il a été réélu ils
devraient se lâcher sur la déco c'est
oublier aussi la moins président je te
mets un jacuzzi
mais nous voilà la machine vous allez
moment j'appelle la sécurité mais nan
j'déconne kad et olivier j'ai la grosse
patate demande moi ce que vous voulez
pour la baraque on voudrait tourner une
suite à mais qui a tué pamela rose
en cette fois les personnages et nous
interprétons les agents du fbi à l'unité
les peurs doivent eux déjoué une
tentative d'assassinât santé d'aller
nourrir tout de suite si tu bouges tess
postale petite gueule de bâtard sur la
prison des états unis d'amérique mais
pensez à prendre je prends ça dans
l'écho nucléaire au cpo tam êtes
vraiment une mère folle pour moi on va
rien toucher un dérangement est ce à
dire
oh
voici avoir besoin de tourner une scène
dans votre gros avions là leur force one
il vous plait et en ce qui concerne
l'armée n'aurait besoin d'une centaine
d'hommes des troupes d'élite 62 cents
200 hommes des troupes d'élite ça serait
super forme une grosse rave party à
guantanamo est-ce qu'on peut tourner un
dimanche on n'a plus qu'une chose à
faire pour sauver la présidente une boum
comment s'élabore yes you can
à mon axe mais qui a retué pamela rose
tata yoyo
qu'est ce que c'est que ça a besoin qui
était passé pour la bande-annonce a
toujours bien d'avoir des filles sexy
bons enchaînements